hey this is it with GameSpot and I'm
here with Carrie from tiny bill how are
you good how are you doing I'm good and
you're here to show us hello neighbor
now this is a little bit it's quite
anticipated without audience so tell us
what it's about and want us through it I
guess
sure yeah um hello neighbor is it's a
stealth horror game it's about a kid who
moves in across the street to see his
neighbor doing something really shady in
his house he's kind of got his basement
boarded up and you hear screams coming
out of it so it is your duty as a Good
Samaritan neighbor and a very nosy kid
yeah to break into his house over and
over again until you figure out what's
inside
sounds like my childhood yeah let's
let's run through it okay tell us what
we're doing here great so actually we
start off in our own house it's very
nondescript and there isn't really much
to do here but as we open the door
you're gonna see the neighbor's house
now when we say you know you're gonna
try to get through your neighbor's house
this is what we're talking about this is
his house yeah even within this house
you see there's multiple levels there
are kind of a lot of minigames that
you're gonna find in the house as well
and so if the neighbor doesn't find me
I'm just gonna try to go there he is he
just saw me you probably hear that audio
of him when he hears and sees you the
audio changes and it turns into kind of
a scary game despite its Pixar cartoon
appearance so I'm just waiting for the
neighbor to get off my trail now you can
kind of see so this is the front door
I'm looking at right here and that Brown
door right behind it is actually his
basement so the basement is actually
right in the front of his house but
obviously you're not going to get there
right away so the neighbor has actually
gone around the back so I'm gonna just
bust in through the front door here now
we're looking kind of at his house so
we've got his kitchen here all these
items you see here are interactable I
can pick up items like this chair that
he's using to block the door and now the
back doors open for me I can hit light
switches I can pick up this glue which
can help I can throw it on the ground
oops yeah things like that so this house
is very much a sandbox environment that
you can kind of do things around the
house kind of that just limited by our
own imagination
goodness this great camera so there are
different ways to take out differences
facets of a house yes yeah basically the
house is pretty much you want to get
through the house however however you
want to and there's multiple ways to
solve puzzles and so the way this game
has been developed the developers tight
dynamic pixels that are based in Russia
we've been releasing with them alphas
and betas as we go so basically if you
pre-order the game with us you got to
watch the development and help inform
the development as we go so oh goodness
I think I can see him so you can
probably hear the audio change like when
he approaches you can hear his footsteps
and his reactions when you notices you
in the house getting pretty intense
right now yeah you see how my screen
just shook so when he runs by this you
start to shake with fear when the
neighbor comes by so I'm in a safe zone
right now he cannot find me but you
actually see that I'm security camera in
the corner so the way the AI works is
that the AI learns to play against you
so when you move things around in the
house he'll notice that somebody's in
the house if he finds you in a
particular hallway for example he's
gonna start to set up security cameras
so right now he probably saw me run by
but he didn't see where I went so I'm
gonna not run into him so now we're on
the second floor and here's an example
of one of the puzzles that you're gonna
get this is a kind of a greeted door we
know we want to get through there there
is a switch there's a switch right there
that we can actually try to throw some
items at so if we find some items that
fit through that grate let's try to get
that's my throw button that's we're
gonna try to find let's get some books
some items are too big to fit through
the fence to throw so for example you
can try basically anything you can try
it hands on yeah right so that's gonna
be too big so what I can do is try to
throw it ah that that is not so close
any more items maybe this alarm clock
will do yeah so I mean you could pick up
and throw any items okay that was really
lucky another way people get through it
is that there was kind of an open
opening here so you can stack boxes you
jump into it you can actually also jump
there's an opening here so we give
people the options of kind of how to get
through the game as well and it's
discovery so like I said the game is not
out yet
it comes out in December 8th however
there's already hours and hours of
gameplay everyone's invested into it
just because you know they can literally
just do tons of things in this house
just the house change or we're gonna get
the same house to explore everyone's
gonna get the same house and the items
all start in the same place now one
thing you'll notice is that when we went
through all the different alphas each
house each alpha had a different house
let me get a lot of questions about you
know please put this house back in are
they gonna be in the final game and to
that we say I don't know you're gonna
have the way to put this it's a surprise
it's all a surprise it's a mystery like
much of this game is you know we know
what we're doing and we have a plan for
it we just want to make you guys sweat a
little bit so I didn't try these doors
but these are actually all locked and
then you see here here's like you know
eventually we want to find a yellow key
in the other room there was a blue key
we needed to find so that's kind of your
cues of how to progress through the
house so if you get caught what happens
all he does is he throws you out into
the street you retain your items you
retain your progress through the house
and it's just kind of it's just kind of
a scary thing we this game doesn't
actually have any jump scares though we
get a lot of screaming when people play
it because it's just scary when the
neighbor yeah catches you he's running
at you you hear the sounds and the music
and so that was kind of the basis and
the idea of this game was that it's a
horror game but it sure doesn't look
like right it looks like a Pixar movie
these guys are very colourful design
tastes and also very strange image
placement like that incredibly strange
so what we're gonna do here and look
there's another camera right here so
right now I started this game oh gosh
he's up here we started this game kind
of already having played through it so
that's why these cameras already there
like I said the AI adapts to how you
play so if you're always found in the
hallway or if you're always going
through this back door which is why this
camera is here he's gonna start to like
trap it so he can find you a window and
when you activate it oh goodness I think
he's downstairs
I think that's they just threw it at me
so I think this glue so you just threw
some glue at me and I'm gonna try to run
through it but this is probably not
gonna work very well it'll slow you down
yeah cuz I gotta jump through that so
yeah the same items that you can't use
yeah well he he has um he has glue he
has bear traps and he has security
cameras and this beta of the game again
this is beta 3 luck keys right there
he's not very happy with me so yeah and
then once he actually puts down the
items you can interact with them for
example I can like spring his bear trap
and pick it up so there's a bear chop
right there what I want to do is I could
always jump over it or I can just I can
spring it and he's gonna hear that so
I'm gonna back away a little bit but
you'll you'll you'll find that a lot of
people try to brute-force this game and
as you do that you actually just get
worse and worse at the game because he
sets up more and more traps for you and
so you have to find you know different
entrances or at some point you gotta
take a break from trying to just break
into his house and start to dismantle
the traps he's laid out for you one of
my favorite traps is that he'll actually
leave a door ajar and then put a pail on
top of it so when you open the door
classic normal own mood it's so
wonderful it's very very much home alone
inspired and and things like this I'm
just gonna pick up
and your safe zone is across the street
of your hostess unlike you he has
manners you will not actually he went
Costas could just say yeah but what I
like to do is them I like to throw
things at him she can you in kepada
incapacitate him
you can't sometimes you can get him
caught in a bear trap but he he could
not be permanently incapacitated so in
one of the previous alpha is there were
sleeping pills you could find to put
into his milk so he has a routine he
kind of goes around the house he does
the stretches and things like that
yeah so there are ways to temporarily
disable him but you can't really ever
kind of make him go away completely now
if I hopefully make it through to one of
the minigames I'm gonna try to do this a
little bit more safely um you actually
start to get special abilities as we
complete certain portions of the game
and I will hopefully get there but for
the first for the first there's a camera
I think I'm gonna try to go through the
back window or the first ability that
you get actually in the game this is
kind of a spoiler if you haven't played
any of the alphas is that when you
crouch you turn invisible and that's the
first ability you have to pass the the
fear Supermarket level which I'm gonna
try to get to if I can so now that you
saw that hallway was booby-trapped with
that camera
I can either try to get that camera out
or I can just break in a different way
so he's gonna have a head that
oh he hears that
right here and so there's an air instead
of indication that he's around aside
from the screen shake and the ominous
music yes yeah and well you will hear
the sound effects too so you'll hear
kind of his footsteps walking around
sometimes you'll hear those footsteps on
grass sometimes you'll hear like water
running so you know he's in the bathroom
I think he's close you're getting my
audio right now so yes so there are ways
to kind of know where he is at its own
environmental it's all yes everything's
environmental and you know there's kind
of a story that goes along with it but
it's you know very short cutscenes and
everything is kind of stolen
environmentally so here's the other
shortcut through well it's very close
okay now we're gonna try to make sure
I've all my buttons trying to get that
lid yes
so you see me right now so that jump you
can make that jump if you're better at
platforming that I am but oh he's
upstairs now you see that another way to
do it is to actually find an umbrella
and then you can float across at a Mary
Poppins style which I will do once he
you know jumps off of a second-story
there he's really mad at me so we can
watch where he's going right so he's
going to the right so now I know these
are the type of cues you can kind of
look for there also other ways to
distract him for example if I can make
it in there
so scared right now there's a TV here
and there's a remote mmm so if I grab
the remote and I go somewhere else in
the house and I switch on the remote
he'll hear a noise and try to come find
itself getting stuff talking and playing
- that does it
so Easter eggs right so you're trying to
figure out again how to progress through
the house so if you notice if you look
at these paintings they're all kind of
wonky but this one in particular it's
super wrote something at it that oh yeah
and that also gives me access to other
parts of the house so let's just go
there but can't seem to make that jump
today and then it is gonna open up other
rooms for you this looks like a pretty
standard room but now we have kind of a
lot more access into the house so
there's an after balcony and as you go
higher up in the house you will when you
need to escape right you can actually
jump off then this version you actually
I guess it's not officially fall damage
but you will look there's a time problem
right there
let's just go there but you do have to
restart if you fall too far so we're
gonna jump in oh cool actually this is
kind of a room I wanted to go into so um
again we can shortcut a lot of this
right and so instead of short cutting or
doing what I was trying to do very
poorly we're just gonna get up into this
room which you lead into if you actually
make that jump we're going to hit that
switch there
raises this platform I go into this room
and here's the start of the minigame so
this is what I should have done this
whole time and so we have a set of
levels in the most recent beta they're
called the fear levels right now you'll
notice something very interesting
maybe you probably would notice this
until you played the game a while but
I'm a lot smaller than I used to be I'm
a lot shorter these shelves are a lot
higher and so I'm kind of maybe I'm
excused maybe I'm younger than I used to
be not quite sure so we're pushing this
through a very scary looking
you hear a clattering noise let me know
that's the mannequins running at me and
that's a sound cue I don't have right
now but what you want to do is you see
these mannequins and so I want to look
at what they have in the cart and I'm
trying to get those same items into my
cart that's that's that my new skill so
once I pass this level I actually get
this skill in the main game and what
that is is a Crouch to go invisible so
that's gonna be really handy as we go
through the house as we get higher and
higher and fewer escape paths actually
runners is that really when you stay
still
yes or I guess I'm just crouching right
now and this is something I'm in another
example of feedback we really took from
the players was originally if you just
stand still for a second you will turn
invisible but then people would get
scared by the mannequins they start
moving the mouse and it actually
wouldn't you know it would break the
invisibility so once I pass this level
I've gained the ability to actually have
this crouched and so for example you
know I saw that I saw a big pink tub as
well I'm not sure if there's a green but
let's grab that so you're filling your
shopping cart with five items that you
need
and then these mannequins will actually
try to take things from your shopping
cart as well so there's a series of
these levels within the house so again a
house is way bigger than you think and
each one will give you a special ability
and this one gives you that excite
visibility and there's another one that
gives you a double jump actually can you
imagine how useful that is in the house
and so that's how the game kind of
evolves over time as you play through
and now the most recent version we have
out is made of three that's about only
40% of the content that's gonna be in
the full game so if you play it you're
not necessarily ruining it for yourself
you're just getting a head start in the
game that comes out and I think about a
month and a half now so I only have one
item in the cart this is not gonna end
up working but we get through if you
would if you were to succeed yeah you
see so I have one correct item and then
it sends me back and I have to play
through the level again but that's an
example of the many things we have going
on and so like the minigames the only
way to get this sort of supernatural
powers so to speak and then progress
through I I think I mean for this one
obviously you don't really need the
Crouch ability it's just really nice but
double jump is something that you know
you probably need as you go on makes the
game a lot easier too and again as you
saw I totally failed at getting through
the proper method of actually getting to
this level but you can invent different
ways based off of what you observe in
the house yeah so so many different
options to tackle one problem and that
ultimate goal is to what get up to the
top level and see what the hell he's
doing get into the basement which is
actually again at that that it's right
in front of the door and so it's teasing
you the whole time to see what's down
there and I will say that with one of
our last updates we did reveal or we
have bosses we have boss battles which
function in the same way the game does
it's a platforming battle and also
multiple basements we've we've admitted
that much already this guy has not got
some good stuff going on no he doesn't
I mean this is in his house like what is
this exactly like why is this in your
house cool so remind us again when hello
neighbor is coming out and 2-way yes
hello neighbor is coming out December
8th so very soon for PC and Xbox one and
you can go - hello neighbor game calm to
find out all about it cool thank you so
much guys thank you so much